What makes a good controller?
If I could answer that in a sentence I think I'd make a fortune.
I think the jury is still out.
My opinion is someone who is creative.
And by that, I don't mean an artist, someone who can paint...
...because I can't paint for toffee.
But what most controllers can do is they have a can-do attitude...
...and they have the ability to think outside the box and solve problems.
I'd love to know what the secret ingredient that makes a good controller is.
Do you know what?
There isn't one.
There isn't one ingredient that makes a good controller.
And I think we spend a lot of time trying to focus on on what a controller needs to be.
But everybody's got different strengths, different skills.
And it's not so much about having that one key skill...
...or that one skill set that you can apply.
It's about knowing what your strengths are and your weaknesses.